Yeah, as much as we can be, I had to take a hatchet to break up the ice at the bottom of my driveway because it was so packed in there. Yeah.
When we were, we were, it was after with my son, I was snowblower.
And I said, don't go to the end because the township will come by. And you know, it's always that I learned a long time ago.
go because you get so it's frustrating. It's a lot of work to clear that out and then go back down and clear it out again.
Yeah, yeah exactly. I live in Cinnemundson Harbor right off of Broad Street. I was talking to Lisa yesterday.
I guess her uncle runs JT Vacken so yes.
Yeah so I live in the.
complex right there. And we allegedly have snow removal support, but all they did was
just block us into our driveway. So
in our neighborhood, this last time we got like three weeks ago, two of our neighbors
lost their mailboxes when they came and they cleared out the snow and they were saying,
yeah, they came to the
The truck like they plowed out our mailbox and I said it's impossible
Well, it's anything possible. I said they didn't hit your mailbox
What they did was they were pushing the snow and that snow was so heavy that that bought. Yes
Yes, so now they went and they complained to the township
so
So when they cleared out the road in our neighborhood, they did one pass.
So yesterday I'm trying to get out of the neighborhood and there's a garbage truck
coming in and there's me trying to get out and it was like, oh my gosh, just trying
to get through it crazy.
Yeah, the comedy of errors.
Totally.
Hey, we get that word right? Yeah. Well, nice to meet you. So I know you reached out to us.
Tell me a little bit about what you're doing and what you're looking for. I could tell you what
we do. And if I'm a fit, great. If not, I can always refer somebody your way. Sure, yeah. So,
So just for my LLC at the beginning of the week,
sold proprietor at the moment with no plans
to expand additional employees.
And the main value proposition that we have is,
I have a 10 year plus career in proposal management
for large businesses, helping sales team
to sell services and products.
And so many companies undervalue contributing investment
towards people who do that work.
And so what I would do is come in as a low cost way
to upscale proposal management teams.
And especially in terms of,
of how to use AI to automate huge parts of their job.
And yeah, so that's essentially the pitch to companies
and then to proposal managers and also sales people,
career sales people to provide executive coaching
for that same kind of upskilling.
Cool. Yeah, it's a brave new frontier, right? With AI?
Everybody's worried their jobs are gonna go away. I think it's fun. Oh, yeah, I do too. I've been doing some cool stuff this week. Oh
my god, yeah, I
You know for us it
It's been, they into it's the big company that does QuickBooks and TurboTax and all
that.
I think for 30 years, they've been saying eventually it's going to replace the perfect
ain't going to replace us.
Every all of us thinking human beings will just keep moving.
upstream. Yes, I agree. That's what we do. So, on our way, you come to a good spot, you know, on our side, our clients are monthly clients. They're not, we don't, we, we stop taking on clients just
to do tax returns at the end of the year. We stopped doing that a long time ago. It's just not the
position that we want to be in. It's not fun for anybody. It really is. I mean, I learned like when
I started over 20 years ago, he would do tax returns and then people get upset, not at us,
just the fact that they have money. And then in March they went,
want to have this really long conversation, we'd be like, oh, no. No, we don't want to
talk to you right now. We just want to finish our task and get paid. And we realized that
that's kind of a hard thing to do. And we had no problem finding that business. So we kind
flip the thing around a little bit.
said, you know what, look, you come on board, you become a monthly client. We'll do the bookkeeping,
we can offer payroll, there's the consultative piece, we do planning, advisory, all higher-end
stuff, more value, certainly more budget, and then we'll do the compliance stuff. We'll prepare
the returns and then away we go.
So that had momentum and that's what we've been really doing ever since.
So just kind of break it down even more.
So for us, like, okay, so fees are minimum, it's $500.
If you're just starting out and it's a very simple business, $6,000 a year.
What we do is specifically, we actually will subscribe.
to it, pay for the cost of their service.
Set up QuickBooks Online, and basically we want user names
password. You can give us a third party, limited anything you want to do.
We're fine with, we do it over and over. What happens is people don't want
people are lazy, even me.
They just want to be a little bit more comfortable.
want to give us their logins and they know they're just going to get the MFA on their
phone and have to send us the code anyway. So that's their chat. So that's what happens.
We end up texting, "Hey, we're trying to, you know, token expired. Hey, we're trying to get
in. Can you send us the code?" And then they just copy and paste it. They send us the code
and we get in. We do what we got to do. So we do what we got to do, which is basically
get all the transactions into a general ledger and then do a closing and that generates a P&L
and a balance sheet. Not terribly exciting but you know in our world you got to have some kind of
organization. Why? Why do we need to be organized? Well I mean one is you got to run your business,
two is
I'm doing an audit for two clients. IRS is coming into the office. They've already been here and we're
continuing. You don't have a set of books. That sucks. You got a real problem. So, you have a set
of books. You have some financial statements. You have the ability to get in. You'll be a user.
You won't do any work. There's no work for you to do. We do all the work. But you can get in,
you can run your reports. Reports are done on a lot of bases. And so that just happens throughout
the year. So it's pretty straightforward stuff. Then there's really two touches on our par.
One is in the summer and in the fall,
we'll invite you to Zoom meetings.
And you really don't have to do anything but show up
and listen to me, just talk.
And I'm gonna do two things in those meetings.
One is we're gonna project our taxes,
we're gonna go over P and L's, project our taxes,
and two just have some ideas to save some money.
We're gonna do that two times, one of the summer time
and one of the summer times.
time in the fall. So everybody has a general idea of where they're headed. And then when
we get to this time of the year, it's real simple. If I call Tim and I say, Tim, you owe
$500,000 or you owe $7,000, you're like, okay, more of the same. You already know what the
expectation was.
And then it's not following you and you're like,
well, I have no idea what it is.
Oh, half a million dollars.
I can't do that because I just spent a half a million dollars
on a building.
So that's the peace of mind that you get, which is--
you know where you're headed?
You get ideas.
estate contemporaneous with what's going on. And then also the other, in addition to all of that,
like I said, will prepare the returns. Everything's electronically signed, everything's in a portal.
And then the other piece that's part of the relationship is unlimited consultation throughout the year.
So we plugged that in a long time ago.
It was kind of at the time we weren't sure how to value that.
And we just now it's just like,
if you have a question,
just ask a similar answer and that's what it is.
And that's really, that is the program,
and we basically figure out,
you know, the fate based on the amount of work that's involved. But we always say, you know, starting
off, that's where we're at with this. Okay. Yeah, I think that's fair. And that is what I'm looking
for. I think my delivery, the product tracks that I have are going to be relatively straightforward.
I already have some ideas in a finite way.
architecture put together. So I think that peace of mind and that kind of ongoing support
and also obviously the yearly support as well, that's exactly what I'm looking for.
Okay. All right, cool. Then sounds like we're moving along here. So then the next piece,
I saw the tax return. Obviously, you didn't know that.
have the business last you know in 2025 so you just got underway a couple weeks ago with the creation of the LLC.
So I mean it sounds like you're gonna have you have one bank account, one bank account with me.
I just opened a business bank account, yes.
Okay.
So one bank, yeah, because basically we're looking, you know, I just want to understand
like the amount of work that's involved.
One bank accounts a lot easier than four.
One credit card is a lot easier than five, right?
So if it's one bank account and what are your projections?
just in terms of volume. I'm only asking this because, I mean, you know, if you've got
300 to 400 to 700 transactions a month, that's one, you know, that's certainly more volume
than if there's 100 transactions a month that are going to be in the bank. And I'd imagine
you're working with a lot of service, a lot of professors.
professionals, a lot of corporate, commercial. So just as far as volume, what do you think
just in terms of things clearing? What have you...
So if it's helpful, I can, into that secure portal that Lucid sent me yesterday, I can
put in my financial architecture workbook that I had put
together because then I think that will paint the picture that you're looking for.
Yeah, let's do that. I just want to get a sense of it. I don't know on your an LLC,
same on the number LLC. So that's basically a schedule C inside the Form 1040. If that's
the entity that you're going to be as opposed to, you know, there's a
you morph it into an S corporation and there's, you know, obviously then we have to file a standalone,
you know, big boy S corporate and all that stuff. So that's just kind of, yeah, it's all about nuance,
complexity. As far as what's hard everybody always says,
Yeah, it's not that hard. Nothing's hard for us. Everything's easy. It's just a matter of, you know, the amount of time.
Right.
Yeah, you know, you know, that loopers.
Okay, so I uploaded it, but I'll also just pull it up on my end here so I can help to speak to it.
Mm-hmm.
And...
Okay, I have this open in front of me.
And you were talking about projections,
is that what you were asking?
- Yeah, projection is just getting an idea of volume
because I want to be fair to you,
but I also want to be fair to us just in terms of...
- Sure.
- What work we're going to be doing, okay.
So you're...
basically, I see boss key financial architecture,
'cause there's an,
cool, very cool.
What's your background?
Where were you working?
Where'd you go to school?
I graduated from the University of Connecticut with an English degree in 2012.
And for the last 12 years, I've been working in proposal management for the insurance industry and then a bunch of different industries.
But most recently, the last five years,
but it's the janitorial custodial industry.
- Cool, not a work there too.
- Yeah, no kidding.
- How to work.
Okay, I got you.
All right, so let's,
do this. Let's do this. And you're you're depending upon obviously where this thing lands, just in terms of
the you're ready to get moving along. You're very interested. Sounds like, okay. And you're in a good
place, you know, obviously you can see.
really good reputation. And we've literally just picked up three or four other monthly
just recently. Let's do this. So I want to get a sense again just of how you're
set up. We're going to have one business account, Tim. Is it Timmy or Tim? I go by Timmy.
Timmy, got it. Timmy, just one bank account you're going to be using. That's it.
I mean, I have my personal checking and personal savings that pre-dates the business account,
but yes, I would just have the
one business account.
One business account.
Okay.
How about a credit card?
Are you going to plan on using a credit card in the business?
Yeah, I can.
I mean, that generally is a good financial idea.
I think you should.
Yep.
You've taken out any loans or you're just kind of funding yourself here.
kind of because it's you know your service.
services, there's really no capital investment here.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And just to kind of quickly paint a picture, I lost my job a couple of weeks ago and that's
where that 164K salary figure comes in.
And so what I'm hoping to do, what my interest is.
The intention is to do is to replace that salary and then some with this business. But yes, I don't need an initial capital infusion in order to make this happen.
Okay.
And
are you.
Have you done it?
to be an S corporation or what is your--
- I haven't at this point still just
solar proprietorship.
The only reason that I have that in here is
my wife might potentially pivot back into the workforce
after having been out of it.
And if it would make sense to bring her up,
under the umbrella of this organization, that's the only reason that we would elect
S-Corp so that we could do payroll. And actually very, very salient points you made there.
Because yeah, typically a sole proprietor even in a
professional services role. Got to be really careful if you elect because you got to have the
profile and baby and it's got to make sense for that particular profile. So certainly if the miss is
is on payroll, it makes a very strong argument
and can really bolster what you try to achieve
by ass election status.
- Right.
Okay, so that's kind of cool.
And then you would be running payroll.
So you need payroll service.
Right.
Unless you can open.
Yeah.
I mean, we offer payroll.
There's a pay this pay tax.
We do also do payroll in house too.
That's over and above what we talked about with the monthly service, obviously.
Okay.
Let's do this.
Let me do this.
Let me give me a day.
I want to go through and just kind of revisit what you sent over to me.
Go back, look at the return.
Let's firm up pricing, but I think we're going to be pretty close to where we're at.
I mean, obviously, there's, I'm just thinking off the top of my head.
I don't, there's no transactions right now.
I mean, you just started.
So there's really no, we usually ask clients to send us like one month bank statement.
So we can just kind of take a look at what's gone through the bank accounts and the credit card accounts.
So we get an idea of like the number of transactions that are hitting you clearly.
Right.
So, but yeah, give me a day to go through this and then let's get back on the phone.
Sure.
I think we're probably in a good position here and if it's still a green light for you,
I can put a proposal together, send it over to you.
And then this would be, this is a good time because literally we're in February and just
a little bit more. So it's monthly with the monthly service we're basically doing all of the
previous month, like three to four weeks after the month then. So January is getting done like
the third to fourth week of February. February we get done the third to fourth week of March so
forth and so on and the billing is just an automatic debit every month. 20 days, you know, the two
20 days after the service month.
So let's do this then.
You just look at tomorrow.
As your day tomorrow look.
- Relatively open.
I do have a couple of engagements,
but let me look at it.
- Great, Gordon.
Sorry, I'm gonna do late morning.
I don't like it.
I do have something until 1110, but I can do, I am then open until 1240.
Okay, do you want to do, do you want to do noon?
This way you get a little bit of breather.
from the 11 to 10 to be 15 minutes to just kind of power down a little bit.
Sure. And then we can jump on at 12. And I can't imagine I need any more than, you know, 15 minutes
with your 15, 20 minutes. And then if everything makes sense, we could do a proposal and then
have one to you by the end of the day. Cool. Okay. All right.
Awesome, cool. Then we will speak. I'll send a zoom link for tomorrow at Newton, then.
Okay, sounds good. Thank you. Awesome. Tim, nice to meet you. I'll talk to you tomorrow.
Yeah, you too. All right, take care. Bye. Bye.